See, I can't find this room, actually.
You didn't make it an 8-player room by accident or something?
My game fucking fell.
I knocked my switch off.
Nobody is playing, so I feel like...
Either I have a very courteous chat, or my lobby isn't working.
Okay, let me try.
I knocked my switch.
So now I have to rewatch this cutscene.
I knocked the switch off.
Wait, what?
I knocked it off.
I can't find any rooms.
Search my room ID.
Where's my team?
I put the ID in the thing.
You gotta put in the ID and then the code.
It's in my group chat, noob.
Yeah, noob.
I was gonna ask how was TwitchCon, but then I realized only one of you guys went.
No, I saw you.
Matt went.
Oh, Matt, you did go?
Yeah, he...
Oh yeah, he didn't play in the slam.
I didn't play in the slam.
Brawl Pro played in the slam.
I took him to TwitchCon.
He stayed at my house.
We played Superstars.
Mario Party Superstars.
Wait, so you guys did play Mario Party.
Okay, but it was like on like no sleep, up for 21 hours, and then we played, so I don't even remember.
Okay, I called dibs on Waluigi.
What?
I am Waluigi.
No, I'm Waluigi.
I literally am.
I'm literally him.
How do you change characters?
Okay, I'm trying to figure out how to join this room fast.
Bro left.
I have to switch characters now.
How did you guys do that?
Dude, Waluigi is awesome.
Yeah, he's literally the best character.
What are you, a fucking Mario stan?
Dude, I just like Waluigi.
No, I meant Tony.
Why are you judging the Waluigi pick?
No, I love Waluigi.
That's why we pick.
I'm a Wario guy.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'm still trying to figure out...
Hold on.
You know what?
I made a room and then I gave up on the room because I figured I had to not play Waluigi.
I'm on the hot air balloon.
I'm trying to figure out where the plaza is.
The room still works.
You should be able to try it.
I'm not even at that stage.
I had to watch a cutscene.
What do you mean?
I had to watch a fucking 10 minute cutscene.
You know, I could invite you if you accepted my friend request.
No, I'm not doing that.
He has a reputation to uphold.
He can't just have random people in his lobby.
In Nintendo, I gotta solve a puzzle.
You gotta watch a movie and solve a puzzle.
I gotta do the Da Vinci Code, the House of Leaves bullshit.
What the fuck is this?
Mario Party, Rhythm Kitchen, Toad's Items.
Go to the plaza!
I'm not watching a cutscene!
I guess I clicked Mario Party.
It's explaining to me Mario Party right now.
How do we play Mario Party?
Where's the plaza?
Do I get off the hot air balloon?
Raw Pro and Lazy Mat Man, can you guys show me your room info?
It's in Discord.
Is it the one I did?
No, it's the one I did directly after.
Wait, guys, do I click Mario Party?
Get off the hot air balloon!
I wanted to be the host.
Yeah, well, it wasn't working when you did it.
What did it?
I don't know.
You wanna try another one?
Here, make another one.
End session.
You don't even have a party room and you're complaining about me not being there?
There you go, make another one.
No, I was kidding.
You said you wanted a new player, what?
I'm eating my fucking bread.
You guys just figure this out.
Go back to the other window.
Alright, I'm creating another room.
Here I go.
My bread here.
Come on, guys, what the hell is going on?
Look, the moment we figured this out, we're unstoppable.
I will be- oh, there you go, I got it.
Alright.
Check this- wait, hold on.
Let me know if it works, I'm just spreading cheese on my bread right now.
It's the same thing.
It's the same code.
I just copied yours.
Okay.
I'm joining up.
I'm watching another cutscene.
Okay.
They're explaining about the plaza to me.
They're telling me- That's the last one.
Is that the last one?
I'll never be able to rewatch these cutscenes ever again.
I hope they were not important.
They'll be on YouTube.
When you're done with that cutscene, you press Y, and then put in the information.
Connect to the internet and play with- oh, I should hide that.
I should even show that.
Dude, I can't join it.
I'm putting in the code.
Oh, no, it's not working for you?
That's what happened to me.
Wait, maybe you guys have to be friends.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I see Matt's room, because we're friends.
I'm gonna accept- I guess we'll be friends, Matt.
What do you mean?
Alright.
I guess I'll add you to my friends list.
It says could not join.
Wait, what?
Alright, becoming friends.
Oh, I can see what Bravo has been playing.
He's been playing Luigi's Mansion.
That was like two years ago.
Luigi's Mansion for five hours.
Stardew Valley, whoa.
For three hours or more.
This guy played Minecraft for 45 hours on the Switch?
You played Minecraft on the Switch?
What the fuck?
This was half a decade ago.
This was so long ago.
45 hours on Minecraft on the Switch.
Bro, why do you have 45 hours on Minecraft?
And he's like old, old.
So he was like 28 playing that game.
Oh my god.
Don't even get me started on how the oldest person was training for all the Mario Party mini-games.
You're talking about that.
And he's out here playing fucking Minecraft.
You watched YouTube on the Switch?
You have a PC for that?
They don't have Netflix on there.
I was in bed, dude.
Why can't I watch YouTube?
Alright, bro, I sent you.
Wait, but don't you have a phone?
Don't you have a phone?
Okay.
Watch out for my icon.
Don't get scared.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
If you close your eyes, it feels like you just got hit by Mario.
Right before the fist comes in.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, Matt's...
Oh, he has...
Oh, hey.
His is not as bad.
His actually has actual games on his recent blade.
No!
Okay, I'm in.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm a gamer.
Alright, Matt.
What's the 4-digit passcode?
It's the same thing.
Okay.
Who the fuck picked Waluigi?
I don't know how to switch.
I can't believe it.
My thumbnail has me as Waluigi.
You're trying to say...
I will switch.
I'm literally lying to my viewers right now that I'm not playing Waluigi.
I don't know how to switch.
Wait, you talked to Toad.
Over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Talk to him.
Nevermind, it doesn't work.
Nevermind, nevermind.
Maybe it's not letting me join because someone already picked Wario.
Even though I was Wario.
Because Cody is Wario.
What the fuck do I play?
Collectively picked Waluigi.
I'm going to be in.
I can't believe it.
Where do you switch characters?
I know where to switch characters.
It will be faster.
You join as Wario.
I will choose my main.
I'm being a shy guy.
It's fine.
Really?
Oh my god, thank you.
I don't want to clickbait my viewers, guys.
That's the only reason.
I didn't want to do it, but you made me do it.
I had to pick my main character.
Wait, what's your main character?
It doesn't matter what character you play.
Oh, it does.
And that is the opinion of a Mario Party noob.
You know, it makes me less of a nerd when you say that.
I don't claim them.
I've seen their recent tweet.
I have relinquished the Overwatch title.
Very wise.
Alright, make a room.
Where's the room at?
Oh, me?
I got you.
Boom.
Create a room.
Alright.
I feel like it's my fault.
I hope everybody can be...
You can hear everybody, guys, on my chat.
He's Boo now?
I am not Boo.
I am Boo.
It's the next quirky character I can think of.
Why are you judging his picks?
Yo, I have not gotten a single pick as an A-OK from Kony so far.
Wait, what's the password?
I never looked at it.
Oh, there it is.
It doesn't even matter.
They can see my password.
It doesn't matter.
They have to be friends with you anyway to join.
Oh, true, true, true, true.
Okay, I'm in.
Let's go.
Is it really the Wario thing?
That's crazy.
I'm in too.
We're figuring it out, guys.
We're figuring it out.
Alright, preparing for the party.
It's party time.
Yay!
Are you guys ready?
Ready to destroy Kony.
Okay, guys, alliance.
I like this run.
I won't be shy guy, actually.
Kony, I swear to God, dude.
Oh, it is cute.
I'm already shy guy, man.
Oh my God.
What do you mean?
I thought you were going to play your main.
I thought you were going to try, Kony.
Are you going to give up now?
Are you scared?
Are you fucking scared?
We need to play it.
First to five.
You guys are beefing.
You guys got to settle that.
Alright, I'm ready.
How do we start the room?
Over here, right?
Do we just go up the balloon?
Oh, we do.
We all ride the balloon.
Slime's not here because he was busy.
Yeah, he's busy watching the stream.
Wait, is he watching the stream right now?
Slime, why aren't you here?
Mario Party.
Friends.
Ah, there you go.
Hey, can we do the mall level or the race cars?
I was going to ask that.
Toki's actually reading this.
Guys, what did it say?
Look at you peasants reading.
A to jump.
I skipped 15 minutes of cutscenes.
I don't know what's going on.
I don't know.
90 minutes?
Isn't that like 2 hours?
It's not 2 hours.
That's not 2 hours.
It's like a low estimate.
The estimation they gave us is low.
It shouldn't be 90 minutes.
Oh, it's 10 turns?
Oh, never mind.
Usually, we go 15.
Minimum.
Bonus stars to who gets robbed at the end.
Isn't that bonus stars?
Yeah, bonus stars on.
I mean, that's the essence of Mario Party.
We're gamers.
It doesn't matter.
That's how I win.
Okay, turn it off.
I played a match earlier.
It was fine.
Who's on Wi-Fi?
See, I didn't know it was going to be like this.
I can...
Wait, wait, wait.
Listen, guys.
I have a cord, but it will just take me 5 minutes to run that 100-foot cable upstairs.
We can see how it runs.
Do you have an adapter?
Yeah, I do.
My router is literally right next to me, so I'm okay with having Wi-Fi.
Did I pause the game for everyone?
Yeah, I did.
Oh, shit, my bad.
I was trying to skip it.
Alright, maybe it'll work.
If it doesn't, I can go set it up.
Yeah, he's like literally in the basement away from the Wi-Fi.
Nope, not anybody's first time.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Doki said yes.
Sorry.
It's my first time.
Sorry, Mr. Mario Party knows everything about everything.
He fucking played the game 2 hours before he could have.
Wait, you can't just have me explain this and then skip everything.
If you wanted to read, go ahead.
Take your opportunity.
I can't read this.
I'm not a speed reader.
What are the pads for?
Doki hit A.
Yo, what is that?
This is Cody's fault.
I heard Doki hit A and then I hit it.
This is your fucking fault.
That's a 5.
You can't read.
Why is Waluigi punching his face?
Damn, those renders are HD.
Holy shit, man.
Just wait till it's switched to...
I can't wait.
Do you guys see the Pokemon leaks?
Yeah.
I mean, all of a sudden, it feels pretty clean.
I don't know.
Yeah, this feels okay.
Maybe it was just rendering.
Maybe it's just trying to figure out where you were.
It feels good now, right?
I mean, I'm hitting A.
It's working.
I mean, we'll see when the minigames happen, I guess.
I just feel like when I hit that dice block, it was fairly responsive.
Oh, I just...
Were you guys figuring out what to hit?
Vroom vroom.
Set, go!
Yay!
Sorry, I must take a look at the board.
Oh my god.
It's the first turn.
Three times a game.
Good game.
Yo, what's happening?
I'm running a jump pad.
Wait, what's the jump pad?
Man, I wish I knew what the jump pad was.
Where are you going with this?
I don't know.
It said hold L or R.
I kind of did.
Oh, to fast forward.
Well, if you actually read the rules, you might know what the jump pad was.
Look around?
Okay, sorry.
I'm looking around.
Dude, look in while we see nothing.
Alright.
We're good.
We're ready.
Alright.
I'll take it.
Vroom.
I like that.
Nice red bean.
You lose coins.
Alright, Pony's turn.
I have nothing.
You had 10.
You start with 10.
I'm giggachatting.
I'm not even looking at the board.
That's right.
You saved me.
He's already memorizing.
Yo, big, big, big.
Hey, you got lucky.
You got lucky.
Get two stars.
Wait, what's this?
I mean, that's whatever.
Wait, you get to steal the coins?
And I'm gonna get your coins.
Now that I'm ahead of you.
Alright.
See ya, loser.
Bye.
Oh, hey.
What do I have?
Oh, what's the mushroom ticket?
Use which adds plus 5 to 2 or 4 times.
That seems kind of broken.
Wait, what about that golden dice?
Wait, you can't afford that yet.
That's like a custom dice block.
I'm gonna get the mushroom ticket.
That seems more...
Uh...
Fuck, okay.
No, I'm gonna go triple dice.
That's where the money is at.
I didn't know this game had a quadra dice.
That's insane.
Yeah, that's for this course only.
I think they added it for this game, right?
It's for this map only.
Like, the whole idea is that you go really far really fast.
Alright, I'm ready.
Oh no, a creepy dice block!
Wait, what the fuck is a creepy dice block?
Oh!
So you get one to three.
I can make you guys... I know who to use it on.
Wait, I already have no money, so...
You have seven cents.
Oh, one to three?
Yeah, let's beat his ass.
Alright, let's beat his ass.
Dude, what is this?
Let's beat his ass.
It is based on the space you land on.
It is based, I agree.
Beat his ass, bro.
Alright, what's this?
Oh no!
I hate this one!
Wait, we're friends now.
Don't get me!
Wait, how do we... Oh, so we have to run away from him.
Oh!
So he...
There's no way he's gonna get us.
I figured it out.
You ain't getting my ass.
This is fighting game mix-ups.
As long as one of us lives, we win, guys.
We just need... I have to get all three to win?
That's crazy.
That's one to three.
I'm stalling, I'm stalling, I'm stalling.
Yeah, me too.
Wait, guys, guys.
Oh!
Wow!
That's fine, that's fine.
Lag switch, lag switch.
He's getting frustrated, he's lag switching.
He's lag switching, he's lag switching.
No!
He's lag switching!
That's alright, that's alright.
How will I ever deal with this?
26 seconds.
No, no, we...
Yep, yep, yep, yep, I like that.
I like that.
That's the wrong person.
That's you!
You picked up yourself.
Okay, I see what you're doing.
It's up to you, it's up to you.
Wait, this is kind of free.
Hold on, this is kind of free, actually.
Wait, wait a minute.
Oh, no!
Oh, God!
Wait, my game won't load.
I'm kicking the router.
Kick him out, kick him out!
He's playing on Wi-Fi.
Dang.
I just needed one rotation, I'm sorry.
Yeah, if you rotated one more time, we would have won, bro.
Guys, I saw...
I saw you were a gamer, what happened?
Okay, well, that's a 1v3 game and those are explicitly designed for the one person to win, so...
Yeah, but you should be good enough...
I thought you were good enough to win these types of games.
You've been practicing many games.
I am, but it's a little laggy and I haven't seen that game.
Oh, true, true.
Actually, that's a legacy game.
That game is an older Mario Party.
Wait, how would you know?
I play a lot of Mario Party.
Oh, yeah, which Mario Party is it from?
I think it's from 5.
I hope somebody crashes into you and you die.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it is happening!
He manifested that.
That's crazy.
That's fucking right.
You deserve that.
You didn't clutch it, so that's your kick.
Yay!
Oh, I'll take it.
Oh.
Oh, should I buy what Doki bought?
You don't need it.
Yeah, actually, no.
Buy what I bought.
Roll whatever number you want.
Wait, get the quadra.
Yeah, the quadra looks really good.
You should get it.
I think this would be useful.
You should get the quadra.
You guys didn't play the last Mario Party.
Maybe MatMay, maybe you did.
But the last Mario Party had one of these sticker things.
Yeah.
Except it would go...
What the fuck?
And you could spam it over and over.
That's amazing.
You seem to be the guy that spams.
Did you spam it?
Were you the spammer, Kony?
No, I didn't do that.
You were the spammer, weren't you?
I didn't spam it.
It's a...
seven.
You've got it again.
He has.
You're not even gonna move.
You're gonna be stuck here.
I'm gonna lap you.
Dude, what?
Yeah, he's gonna get lapped.
He's gonna get a three next.
He's gonna get a three.
My turn.
You know what?
Okay, just to be sure.
It's like when you go to the go-karts and one of your friends has one of the shit with no gas in it.
Ain't no way.
You've got it again.
What are you doing?
Wow.
That's creepy, guys.
Just to be sure.
I just wanna make sure we actually lap you.
I just...
That is hilarious.
That is next level.
I hope they run you over too.
Go off.
Okay, actually, no.
I'm gonna go this way.
What is that exclamation?
That's when you get ran over?
That's the one where Matt gets ran over.
I was like, oh, what's this?
Funny color.
And it fucking destroyed me.
Alright, alright.
If this is very laggy, I'll go and plug that shit out.
I mean, the other one wasn't too bad.
This whole thing's fine so far, honestly.
Hot cross blocks?
What's that?
This is my main game.
Oh, this is your main game?
Now I must lock in.
What is this?
Choose the same as someone else.
No one gets it.
Oh.
Oh, so we all have to get different...
Oh, it's literally luck.
It's RNG.
So, it's like, okay.
Alright, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you gotta pick one that the other people don't pick.
Yeah, yeah.
So you gotta make sure you don't pick the one...
Okay, I picked it.
Someone is not picking.
Someone is thinking.
It's a cerebral game.
They want the two.
They're greedy.
I'm not even looking at what the blocks are.
I'm literally just pressing buttons.
I'm letting RNG take me.
Come on, Connie.
Oh my god, Matt, stop!
Matt,
I swear to god, Matt.
I swear to fucking god, Matt.
Don't you fucking...
I swear to god.
I swear to god, Matt.
I'll let it go, I'll let it go.
I swear to god.
Go ahead, go ahead.
Yes.
Wait, you didn't pick?
Why didn't you pick?
My shit was lagging, that's all.
You didn't even pick one.
We definitely know who's the problem here.
We definitely know.
All I'm saying is...
There'll be no fucking way.
Oh my god, no fucking way.
Okay, I'm pulling up Connie's stream.
I'm pulling up Connie's stream.
Don't go for the threes.
It's not gonna work.
Unless I do it.
If I do it, it's gonna work.
Why?
Stop it!
Stop!
You guys are way back there.
This is obvious.
I picked left.
I swear to god, Matt.
First you take my Waluigi, then you...
I swear to god.
I...
I want Matt.
I swear to god.
I went down.
I picked down.
No one picks it.
I went down.
I don't think.
I won't vocalize.
I went up.
I swear to god, if you pick it, you ain't getting shit.
I can destroy Connie.
Whatever you go for, you're never gonna get it.
I picked right side.
I picked right side to win, guys.
You can't win.
What the fuck is that?
I can't win.
You can't win.
You don't get shit.
Someone get the three column.
I'm not getting that.
I'm fucking playing to win on my own.
Hold up, Connie.
Dude, I can't win.
I literally can't win.
Yes!
Let's go!
The comeback of the century!
I like that outcome a lot, actually.
I deserve it.
All I'm saying is that I deserve this more.
I definitely deserve this more.
I thought this was a kid's game!
You took too long to think.
I wasn't thinking.
That's why you're asking for it.
I'm coming for you now.
I'm killing the boo, bro.
That was the craziest play.
The comeback.
I can't believe that I didn't do the same one you're on.
Wait, what's this?
I know, right?
Like, just maliciously.
Wait, where did you go?
What the hell?
That's very dangerous.
Let's see.
Let's see here.
How much are stars?
Oh, I see.
20?
Okay, I'm almost there.
The good thing about going 2 is I have lots of time to get coins.
Can't wait.
Okay, we can just lap you.
7.
Oh!
You need...
That's good, because then you have enough time to get stars.
Yes.
Pro said yes.
Yeah!
That's how math works.
Oh, and he gets a triple dice, too?
Yo, I'm getting Mario Party'd right now.
Alright.
I wonder what you're gonna get.
1, 2, or 3.
I cast Mushroom Spell.
Does it kill the other one?
Cancel.
Okay, okay, some kind of play happening.
Creepy dice.
But you wasted...
Dude, if he got 3 that time, I would've cried.
What are we doing with the 13?
Nah, I'm keeping me money.
Ow, I can't believe you wasted that mushroom for this.
Oh, what is this?
Go up!
Go up, Cody!
Go left, Cody.
Don't you wanna know what happens?
I wonder what will happen.
Actually, that is a good question.
What will happen?
Wait, wait, what do you mean?
I like that you can see the skin marks.
You get the star, and I get a happening point.
Wait, why did you pick that route?
Because you also have to run.
Oh, you guys both at the left!
Well, well, well.
Ain't no one getting the star today.
Nobody's getting that star.
This is gonna be the first 0 star game.
Hey, guys.
Oh, I'm lucky too!
I always feel like I'm lucky.
Oh, and I got a 7!
Let's go.
Pam first.
Ding, ding.
I hope we get my favorite game.
What's your favorite game?
Uh, it's...
Snag the Flags.
Oh my god, it is!
Oh my gosh, you got your favorite game.
Snag the Flags.
I love this game.
Okay, run around the sphere and capture the flags.
It's grab blue things.
Does that make it snag it from you guys?
Oh, you just grab the flag?
It's literally just grab blue things.
Oh, wow.
I missed it.
Cool, I guess.
Epic game.
Hit start.
He's warming up, guys.
He's warming up.
I'm going up.
Oh my god, fuck you.
Sorry, big dog.
That's mine.
Oh!
Why are they giving Coney all of them?
Those are mine.
Get out, get out, get out!
This is mine, too.
Get out.
Oh my god.
This is literally the Donkey Kong cluster.
Oh, my god.
Oh my god.
Where are they?
Where are the flags?
Where did they go?
I see nothing.
No, who let Kong out?
Who are you guys on the map?
I've been waiting for years.
Excuse me.
Oh my god.
You know what?
I'm going to take a break.
You guys find that last one.
Oh my god.
He has 25!
He has 25 flags!
Because in the beginning he got the perfect freaking RNG.
Some might call it RNG.
Oh, I retracted my teeth.
He has no teeth now.
Oh my god, he's like a baby.
He doesn't feel threatened.
So you guys got so fucked up that he's not scared anymore.
Right.
That's alright.
At least he has no stars.
As long as I'm not fourth place, I'm chilling.
Look, he might have won the minigame, but he has no stars.
With all that money.
Oh, hey Mario.
What is he doing?
As an ally?
Can we read what they're saying?
Oh, okay.
Why is he skipping that shit?
Basically, he lets you buy two stars at once if you want.
Wait, how do we get to him?
Can I get Mario?
Can I have him?
No.
I want Mario.
Oh, I'm getting Mario.
Guess he's getting a traveling star.
Yeah, Mario's in the middle of the road.
Wait, run him over.
It'll be so funny.
Run him over.
Then you can be the new star of Mario Party.
Boo Party.
Yeah, Boo Party.
Oh, the pit stop.
What does that do?
Oh, it's a dice.
Sure.
Does he give you three?
I don't know what this is.
Oh, you got double dice.
He's just cleaning your car.
Oh, cool.
They like do the thing.
Oh, what?
Okay, alright.
Give me a third one.
I don't like that.
Holy shit, man.
From the pit stop?
You're not getting any stars.
You got no money.
But I will have allies and friends before everything.
Friends are on top.
There he goes.
Alright, let's go.
Those who don't win, let's talk about how friendship is the strongest.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, no!
It's Boo!
Oh, you can grab money.
What will it be?
I think you get Doki's coins.
No, no, no, no.
You should get Kony.
He's the one.
Kony can win it all back in minigames.
I'm gonna talk Boo out of it.
He's gonna kill you instead.
Yeah, he's like, give me your stars.
Can you talk him out of it?
Yeah, he's gonna steal your coins and your items.
Oh, minus nine.
I don't know if that's what's happening.
I don't think he's gonna be able to afford any stars at this rate.
If it wasn't for Donkey Kong, he can't speak.
But if it was Mario, he would've scared him away.
Look, they got a camera shot on you.
Oh, I think he's winning your money.
Yeah.
You realize I get Boo now, too.
Yeah, so you should...
hit Doki with that.
Wait, why hit me?
What did I do?
I think you should...
I've just been a...
You hit me with the creepy knife.
What?
You literally cancelled it out.
You cancelled it out.
I never forget.
You cancelled it out, so it means nothing.
I know your ass is not mashing.
Give me 50 coins.
I'm mashing the shit out of this.
I got less stolen than you.
That is true, actually.
Wait, she was gaming.
What the hell?
I wasn't even trying to.
Alright, my turn.
Did anybody hear Waluigi freak out there?
He was like, I want that three.
I'm getting that three in.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, nine, let's go.
Oh, ten, let's go.
That's crazy.
Twenty-seven?
Alright, see you guys.
Don't you fucking dare.
Yeah, you know who I'm gonna get.
I'm getting my money back.
This timeline is the correct one.
That's right.
Give me my money back, Kony.
That's what you get.
You could have chosen to haunt anybody else.
You weren't even mashing.
That's a win.
It's not.
That's just skill diff.
Someone wins.
How the hell did I get overtaken by Doki?
Wait, okay.
What's the board?
Y.
Wait, how many...
Twelve.
Okay, I either get here...
or I get...
here.
Okay, I don't have to land.
You know what?
I'm tired.
I'm gonna make you guys watch even more.
This turn's taking a while.
Yeah, you guys wanna watch even more?
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go this way.
It doesn't really matter.
Alright.
You know what?
Fill that shit up.
Fill the...
Fill it up.
Yeah, with the coins I stole from Kony.
Fill that shit up right now.
Oh, another creepy face.
Wow.
Oh, man.
I wonder...
I wonder what I'm gonna do with that.
You chose...
You chose an enemy today.
I wonder what am I gonna do...
with that creepy dice.
That's fine, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, I get to pick.
You know what?
I think one creepy dice is more than enough...
for me.
Get rid of the double dice.
No, I think one creepy dice is more than enough.
I know what I wanna do.
Targeted harassment to one player...
with a bunch of creepy dice.
To be fair, that one player...
has been a self-proclaimed...
Mario Party gamer.
So like, you know, it's not even targeted.
It's called nerf.
It's a nerf.
Treasure divers double coins.
Wait, if Kony loses this, his career is over.
There's no losing on this one, I think.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, I have to smash.
I understand.
Wait, can I steal from you?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I understand now.
If you go into the shark's mouth, he has a big chest.
Okay, okay.
I'll try.
He's got...
It's a very big secret in Mario Party.
Get me out of here.
Do I have to go straight to the...
No, I just have to take it above.
Alright, I figured it out.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh-oh, it's Mr. Big Chest.
I got one too.
Why is the blooper targeting me?
Oh, no!
All of you, all of you.
Oh, yeah.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Wait, what is up with the blooper?
What the fuck?
Why is he targeting me?
That's so fucking disgusting.
That's fine.
Get away from me.
This is a hate crime.
Get away.
Okay.
No!
Oh, you got so lucky there.
That's fine, that's fine.
Is this a plundered treasure?
Oh, I'm gonna fucking die.
Body, body, body, body, body, body.
Body, body, body, no!
Yeah.
You almost killed him.
We could have made him drown, guys.
We could have drowned him.
If we all blocked the surface, he couldn't come up.
Exactly.
He's already dead anyway.
It's not like anything bad's gonna happen.
That's a lot of coins.
That's fine.
One of us just has to hit the star.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, here he is.
Five, five, five.
Get a two, get a two.
Get a one or a two.
Isn't he lucky if he gets one, though?
Wait, really?
The clover is up there.
Should I give him the creepy dice?
Oh my god.
He's got it!
He's got Mario.
Mario, I love you.
Mario, say no.
He gives you money?
Wait, oh, you have to win.
Shut up, you have five stars and a tip.
Wait.
Oh, if you win.
So you have to win this mini game.
But I get an advantage.
He got an advantage because he's last place.
No, I got an advantage because I found him.
No, it's because he's last place.
It's okay.
We gotta get Mario, guys.
If you get the main character, you basically win the game.
I feel like Mario is just a wincon.
Yeah.
How do we do it?
Mario is creepy.
I think this is like three mini games that we play.
No mini games with your Wi-Fi.
It's fine, it's just loading.
Oh, it's this.
It's flag.
What does that mean?
Oh, it's loading.
So the flag thing is for the other mini games, I think.
This one is just jumping.
How does he know that?
Oh, so I just move it.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I see.
I see how to play.
Someone's not hitting it.
I got locked in.
I don't know what happened to me.
I got overtaken by games.
Mario, you're going down.
Okay.
Boom!
I like that.
Put that lag switch on right now.
Put that lag switch on right now so he'll fall.
Alright, you got it.
Woah!
He's actually doing it.
Woah, he's really doing it.
Wait, he's really doing it.
Woah!
It was a joke.
You have to be joking.
He's actually lag switching.
That's fucked up.
Oh my god, again!
I want to jump!
That is insane.
That lag was fucking crazy.
Holy shit.
Oh, he stopped the downloads.
Okay.
We're stopping the torrents now.
Who are you downloading, bro, bro?
Who are you fucking downloading?
That's insane.
Oh my god.
The game's over, restart.
Calculating.
We'll figure it out.
Despite all the adversity.
Somehow.
What the hell?
Yeah, somebody was hitting me hard with that fucking lag.
That'll be fine.
Wait, it's not even points.
That is crazy.
Oh my god, I'm carried.
Wait, that's not fair!
I am carried.
I'll say it.
Kill Boo, get red.
We gotta get red.
Get Boo, get Boo.
Get your coin right now, bro.
1, 2, 3, subscribe to you.
Get his ass.
I'm going over.
Cody, this is your job.
You're better at this than me.
Oh my god.
Kill Boo.
I'm trying my hardest.
With this lag.
I'm trying.
Get it, boys.
I blame you, Cody.
I blame you.
This is your fault.
Get Boo.
How?
Get him, Mario.
Oh my god, thank god.
I died for the cause.
I was lagging, guys.
That's my reason.
I'm gonna grab a cough drop while you guys figure this shit out.
Get him, Mario.
Get him.
Kill him, Super Mario.
That's my goat.
Mario, we can both win.
We can just draw here.
What if Mario wins?
Then he leaves.
You guys are losers.
You lost to me?
Oh shit, it's you and Mario?
No, we're friends.
We're bumping.
That's fine with me.
I'll tie with Super Mario.
Bro, it's not fair.
Mario's literally an NPC.
He can't lag.
No, we're friends.
You're just vibing.
He's kinda strong, though.
Wait, he's trying to fuck you up.
We could've been friends.
Well, well, well.
Five, three...
One point for the Boo.
Oh my god.
We'll never know how many points Boo gets.
We'll never know.
Wait.
Just wait for it.
Surely I'll get...
You can come back.
What the fuck did you just do?
I think we're able to join back.
Usually you can join back when you DC.
It should be fine.
Let's take one more.
Yeah, don't worry.
The NPC will fucking help you.
I'll go plug it in while you guys do that.
Okay.
Left!
Oh, come on.
Coney, who do you think I am?
Okay, I figured it out.
Where's the mixup?
Matt, are you streaming?
No.
Oh no!
No!
I'm just like an NPC!
I thought the event when he put two out, you press two of it, so I pressed two of it at the same time.
What is he doing?
He's gonna kill you.
He's gonna kill Mario.
Yeah, what is he thinking about?
Goodbye, Mario.
Oh no!
Oh, this game is never gonna end.
Not if he goes this slow.
This game is never gonna end.
If it's this slow, it's very easy to react.
Oh yeah, I'm ready.
Alright, I'm looking.
Disconnect again!
Oh, you son of a bitch!
Alright, bro.
Oh, nobody wins.
Hey, hey, great game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, good game.
However, I did have one more point.
Oh, you do?
As you know, Super Mario is mine.
I can't believe this.
I can't believe it.
Oh, Mario's so happy.
He loves me.
Yeah, Mario was like, thank god I don't have to hang out with that guy.
Who's smell, bro?
Oh, he smells terrible.
Wait, does that mean like nobody...
I don't think you get him.
Oh, you get him!
Hop in!
Does he just run really fast?
This is exactly why.
This is exactly why we give him all the creepy dice.
Oh, he's so sad.
I have to get to the star in three turns.
I don't think that's happening.
He's so sad.
Look what you did.
You made him sad.
Wait, so is Brawl Pro still out?
Yeah, he is.
I don't know, but it's definitely smoother, I'll tell you what.
No, the Wi-Fi is a little better.
I'm doing good now.
Wait, why did you get a pipe?
It's useless.
You don't even know where you're gonna go.
Yeah.
I guess you could say that.
No.
Alright, I know what I'm gonna do.
So is it just a computer now?
I guess so.
Yeah, it's just a computer.
Oh, he's gonna use his blocks.
Oh, that's fucked.
The CPU is really good.
Yeah, that's true.
What if it's like the ultra hard mode CPU?
Oh, shit.
He's definitely getting the bet.
What?
Yo.
Well, he's lapping Brawl Pro, that's for sure.
I mean, not lapping Coney.
Yeah.
Oh, did you get somebody in there?
Oh, he got Jonas.
Oh, I would've done that then.
I'd quote him.
Because it was like, wait, he's lapping people.
Wait, he actually might be a better player than Brawl Pro.
What if he just spends all his money on dumb bullshit?
Oh, he gets another triple dice?
Yeah, this guy's kind of moving.
Yeah, this guy's kind of smart.
Alright.
But watch this.
Alright, we're watching, I'm watching.
Come on, Mario has a car.
You have to get it in three turns.
I gotta put this down, I guess.
I'll leave this shit back here.
Versus...
I'll put it right there.
Oh, that has double advantage.
Oh.
Alright, uh...
Come on, Mario, let's get a big roll.
Okay.
And then plus five.
Mario, it's go time.
Put a five on that.
Okay.
Wait, uh...
Go right, go right.
It's actually tough, cause...
I only have him for three turns.
If you go right, you get extra items.
Yeah, honestly, I would too.
I would have to give up ten, so it's like, do I do...
I don't know.
That went right.
Alright, my turn.
Okay.
Oh, I like that you can see the turns on the bottom, I just realized.
Double dice time.
Alright, I believe.
Okay, not that one, but now.
Yeah, I believe now.
Eleven, no roll.
Hey, where are you again, Kony?
Where are you on the board again?
I'm working.
Where are you?
Can you remind me?
Okay, let's see.
I'll grab the...
Oh, I can grab the double.
This game is way smoother now, all of a sudden.
Yeah, it feels like we're not lagging anymore.
Yeah, okay, another double.
Ain't no way she didn't want the quad dice.
Alright.
Oh, hey, I'm right next to Brawl Pro.
Let's go.
Minigame.
Uh-oh.
Play my favorite game.
Scare yourself.
Actually...
Wait, what's that?
I don't know.
It just sounded cool, you know?
Just for Halloween, yeah.
Oh, this is scary.
Oh, you just avoid people.
You gotta jump over.
You have a really high jump in this game.
Alright, I'll figure this out.
Watch this.
Wait, why are you guys...
I'll wait.
I'll wait my turn.
It's cool.
You shouldn't have waited.
Nothing.
Yeah, you guys waited.
Why are you guys waiting?
Why are you guys so scared?
Why are you guys...
I need you to stop doing that.
Why are you guys so scared?
There's like no threat here.
Yeah, there's no threat.
We're just walking around.
It says there's 30 seconds.
Oh, it's getting fast.
Oh, I realize...
Now I know...
Oh!
Why did I play slower?
Okay, okay.
Guys, wait up!
No, no, no!
No!
Why did you go so fast at the end?
I was ready!
That game was too scary.
That's where the scare was.
I didn't like that one.
I liked that one a lot.
That one was not fun.
Get up so fast!
With all that money...
And no stars...
What's the point?
But I can get two stars with my good friend, Super Mario.
I think it really depends on where I'm going to send this card to.
Only if he gets to hit a star.
After I take it.
Oh, he has to double.
So he could get 10 right here.
I'm going to put it right in front of me.
Watch this.
What do I need?
I need a 5 and a 5.
Come on.
Oh!
What?
That's so not...
Oh my god.
What was it?
What did you hear?
Yeah?
Why?
Because you're too old?
And I'm too young?
Very funny.
It's a three stooges bit.
Give me that star.
Three stooges.
Well, well, well.
Is that closer?
It's like the same distance, I feel.
Oh, I like that.
It's the same distance as you?
It's like gold dice.
Oh my god.
Oh, I wanted that.
Hey man.
If anyone tries to curse dice me, I will be cleansing.
Alright.
I know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to say hi.
Hi.
Waluigi.
Turn that off.
Yeah, this guy can't roll dice.
Okay, he got it.
Dude, he's going to get a star.
Wait, is he?
Oh wait, what?
He gets a star while not even playing the game.
He didn't even do anything.
He's not even here.
He's not here.
This is bullshit.
We have to kick him out right now.
I'm feeling devious behavior.
Oh my god, where's the next star?
Oh nice, it's on me.
Damn it.
That's right, you're too far.
What?
I hate a minigame.
Who wants to fight for a fucking mushroom?
We don't get to see.
Oh, I guess the CPU plays it.
Oh, did he win?
Come on, Mario.
I guess let's keep going.
He's going to leave soon.
How's that Mario treating you?
Mario, can you stick around for like two more turns?
Oh, you have 25.
Oh, what?
Wait.
That's Ash.
Can you use more than two items?
Can you use more than two items per turn?
Wait, I think...
Well, that's an old mechanic.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait, where's that shop?
Where's that store?
Wait a minute.
You wouldn't happen to have a quadruple dice, would you?
Good heavens.
Thank you.
Wait a minute.
I need your finest oil, please.
Wait, two items?
Wait, you get to have two items?
No, I just...
You might as well get a mushroom ticket now.
Maybe I'll treat myself.
Do I want the mushroom ticket or the...
You might as well get the custom block just in case.
I think I'll treat myself.
Okay.
No way!
Oh, wait.
You better not lose.
Thank you, Mario.
Mario got hit too?
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh my god!
And he loses money for you.
You better not win the next video game.
Alright.
This is it.
Oh my goodness.
This is my only chance to take this from him.
You gotta.
Legendary.
No!
It's a no!
I don't even want to watch.
I don't even want to look at Kony taking this star.
Why is Mario behind you now?
Mario has overtaken your game.
Oh my god.
I am back, but it doesn't let me join back.
Wait, does he?
Oh, he's mine now.
Goodbye, Kony.
I got Mario.
I stole Mario from you.
Yoink!
He's mine now.
I'm so far from you.
You can't steal it back.
We gotta get BroPro back in.
I think we start over.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we start.
Alright, we start over.
Wait, are you sure you can't join back?
Usually you can.
Wait, hold on.
Am I back?
It says I'm standing by.
Yeah, it's after it turns over.
He joins back.
That's why.
Oh yeah, because it was taking forever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, how does this work?
You want to get coins, so you do the turn styles.
Yeah, if you're on the button, it turns 90 degrees one time.
Oh, so we just keep pressing it.
I cannot believe.
You can't even buy a double star.
BroPro, you got carried by your NPC.
Wait, really?
Did he pop off?
He literally got you a star.
That's my coast.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Yeah, I wanted three, but we'll take the one.
Okay, nice, nice.
We got the one.
That's fine.
NPC, he knows what he's doing.
Yeah, you know what to do here.
Yeah, I got you.
Yeah, you know what?
You know what?
Oh my god.
Right, right, right, right.
I mean, that happens.
Yeah, let's go!
BroPro would've fucked that up.
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
I've got the gamer.
Let's go.
Wait, this one's fucked up.
Hold on, we have to see.
We have to know what to do based on what the NPC does.
Yeah, yeah, we have to.
We just got mixed.
That's crazy, that's crazy, that's crazy.
Let's go, BroPro.
BroPC!
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Maybe you can just watch.
He's pretty easy.
Okay, you make a move, and then I'll make a move based.
I have to help you.
Oh my god, it didn't do my input.
You won't lose anything here.
That ShyGuy is crazy.
That's just not fair.
That ShyGuy's fucked up, wait.
You know what?
I'm just doing this, because we need to get something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I told you, that's all you have to do.
There's no way to beat the CPU, so I'll leave it up to you.
That's literally all you have to do.
Oh, great.
Oh, baby.
You caught up!
How many rounds is this?
It's on the bottom.
Oh, shit, okay.
If we both stand... no.
If we both stand on, I think we're good.
I didn't copy the bot.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
What's going on?
Are you fucking serious?
No way, are you serious?
Brawl PC, what are you doing?
Those mind games.
Brawl PC, you were supposed to be gaming.
That's calling a bot pro.
I like that.
Oh, my God.
And we're off.
Oh, I didn't react in time, I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
We got major from that.
That was good.
I can't believe it.
I blame bot PC.
The pre-game jump for mind games was the difference maker there.
Mario for me, my beloved.
Were you guys actually counting?
Because I wasn't.
Matt took first place.
Oh, yeah, I kind of popped off a little bit.
It's because he had the star and the coins.
So you're back in?
Yeah, let's go.
We're just starting now.
Goodbye, Mario.
Let's go somewhere you don't even know where to go.
Yeah, it's a random spot.
You guys want to go on a side quest?
Craziest play of my life.
You didn't even earn that.
Wait, and then he can fucking get that star.
Let me get it.
I'm fine.
Unlock the space.
Move guys immediately.
Oh, my God.
What if all of you never make it to the star, though?
Hold on.
I would say that if I didn't have...
Turbo Dice.
It doesn't matter.
You don't even have Mario.
I don't have Mario.
I'm really mad about it.
If you're three to eight spaces away from the star by the end of this turn, we'll know the culprit.
I'm okay with a hit and run.
You can't get stars with turbos.
That's my chat.
Oh, my God.
God bless you for telling me that.
Everybody in chat is going to be so mad at you for telling me.
But I'm glad one person in chat loves me.
I'm okay with that.
Hey, that's information for me.
What if he's lying?
What if you're getting one guide right now?
I'll read the item.
Oh, a lot of coins here.
Just take everything from him.
Just take everything.
You have a lot of coins, man.
You do have a lot of coins.
I'm getting 64.
Can we get 9 from him?
He's stealing from the rich.
He's poor right now.
Thank you.
It's like you didn't lose any money.
Give me my money back.
I did that on purpose.
Come on, man.
That's sweet.
Let me read these item descriptions very carefully.
Oh, that's crazy.
I can't believe.
I can't believe you're getting your hand held by your chat.
End the two-hour warm-up.
Exactly.
Only one guy said it.
Everybody else in chat wasn't saying anything.
They wanted you to fail.
That's crazy.
Yeah, but it's only one star.
He doesn't even have his friends.
You know what the saddest thing about this is?
It's going to move behind you.
Oh, come on, do it.
It'll be so funny.
One star, please.
Thank you.
That was a good Donkey Kong.
Now he's in the first.
Yes, he is.
Oh my god, Seth Rogen, is that you?
Two slots for the star on this entire stage?
Oh, man.
Why doesn't it go fucking...
Oh my god, I swear to god.
Oh, just what I needed.
Genie, please.
Oh, a minigame.
I get to play a fun game.
Golden pipe, perhaps?
Maybe a golden pipe.
What is this?
Stop the wheel.
What wheel?
Wait.
I know this game.
No.
What are you going to get?
I want to know what that gold dice does.
That one right there, right?
Yeah.
What'd that do?
Surely it's...
What is it?
Tell your chat to tell you.
We're the backseaters.
I didn't understand that game.
Hello, Mario.
As soon as it hits a line, it has to take it.
It hurts so bad.
He's looking at you the way he used to look at me.
Oh, hey Mario.
You like being with me instead of him?
Yeah, don't ya?
That's alright.
I knew he couldn't do...
He couldn't give you what I could give you.
He's gonna leave you real soon.
Yeah, but at least he left you first.
He knows you're no good.
Oh, I get a gift from my...
Oh, hey!
You gotta be joking.
Oh, man.
Thanks, Mario.
I'm gonna give you what he couldn't give you.
I need somebody.
There's gotta be somebody out there for me.
Oh, okay.
I have a lot of money, so I can...
Let's see.
Oh, I can purchase two items.
Okay, I'm gonna buy the triple block.
What's that quadruple one?
That's the turbo one that Kony didn't use.
Yeah, so it's turbo, but you can't get stars with it.
You, like, run past it.
Okay.
Nah, I'm fine.
That's bad, then, if you can't get a star with it.
Yeah.
Well, I think I'm about to use it next turn.
And I think it's good, because I'm kind of far away.
But I don't want to overshoot.
There's no way you can overshoot.
Unless you get all tens or some shit.
Why would you cheat me?
Oh, how many benefits does Super Mario give you, man?
You had him for two turns, Kony!
What do you mean?
Yeah, I have a bunch of ops.
You already know how it is.
Snowball?
What's that?
Oh my god, we're actually gonna beat his ass.
Yeah, I have a bunch of ops.
It's okay.
Wait, he has monkeys?
Make Snowball...
Get him!
Oh, it's like...
It's dodgeball!
Get him!
Why is this 1v3?
One shot kills.
What?
No, not me!
Broppo literally just hit me.
That is insane.
Why did he friendly fire?
I got him!
I got him and he just let him go!
I'm too scared!
I'm too scared right now!
What do you mean?
One shot, one kill.
Let's go.
VTuber of the year, guys.
This is my highlight clip.
I'm sending over.
Get him!
This is the clip I'm sending over to the VTuber Awards.
Right there.
Bye!
Mario's gonna go work on himself for a little bit.
Aw, Mario left!
Alright, what can I do?
We're gonna do...
Of course.
Wait, I just realized my next play.
What are you gonna do?
Alright, man.
Oh, no.
Getting ready to alley-kick.
Well, it's a little bit stronger than that.
What does he have?
He only has the quad dice.
Oh, I got something.
Honk's looking at the board.
He's thinking right now.
Why can't I do this?
He pulled out his bifocals.
You have a decade!
Grandpa at the dinner table.
What's in the news today?
I'm checking Twitter right now while we wait.
Happy Endy.
Got the trifold out.
Go up, bro.
Scared.
Yeah, baby.
What are you scared of?
It's a kid's game.
Oh, that's a lot of coins.
Wait, that's a lot.
Not even good.
Alright, let's see what's Coney's big brain idea is.
Play of the game.
This dude got the Zelda inventory.
You can't even get it.
You can't even get it because you need 48.
Abagados los luches!
You're sucking my ass!
My old man's ass!
Your value is terrible!
Get closer!
Where's it gonna go?
Was that a boo?
Aw, you missed the boo!
Lowest value ult I've ever seen.
Was that the play you were looking for?
That was the play of the game, by the way, guys.
Right there, that was the play of the game.
That's insane.
Nice.
Yay!
21?
That's pretty big.
That's where the star is, right?
Yeah, you got the star right now.
Right?
Yeah, that is.
Gotta be sure.
I have two ults.
I think there's only two star spots.
Aw, if only Mario was here right now.
I thought there were three.
Because I thought there was two in the back and one in the front.
Wait, you took...
I mean, maybe.
I just feel like...
I took the star, so it's gonna move now.
Okay, where's it gonna go?
Back up.
So it goes up now.
It just goes up and down?
I thought it'd go...
Does it not go anywhere else?
For this map specifically, probably.
Oh, hey, boo!
Yo, what's good?
Oh, hey there.
Yeah, give me some coins.
You know what?
I have the least.
Thank you.
It's just practice.
It's like bashing.
It's gonna help in the game that has button bashing.
There's no way.
Yay!
I've been unfairly targeted by three miscreants all get... Oh, do the verse.
Give me my points back.
Yay!
Who am I versing?
This is important.
This is a big minigame.
Oh, that's a lot.
Oh, that's a lot of our coins.
80 coins!
And it's gonna be my favorite game.
Three!
Sled to the edge.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Okay, we all know what to do, right?
We all know he was not...
I've never seen this one.
Watch the example closely.
Okay.
Watch and learn from the toads.
Oh, it's like...
Oh, easy.
Okay, understood.
It's like that Canadian sport game.
How do you know though?
What was that Canadian sport game?
Watch the example.
We gotta watch...
This is the length it'll be at.
Yeah, this is them.
Yeah, this is the length.
Anyone count?
Yo, red toad went too far.
Red toad didn't?
Oh, curling!
This is curling!
Alright, alright.
It's just A, I think.
It's literally curling.
Okay, I got this.
You guys are going down.
Oh...
Alright, guys.
Oh, he's so early!
Damn, we are ass!
No!
Yo, where is the finish line?
I heard the click.
And then I got nervous.
I got nervous as I heard it.
We were frightened.
I think everybody...
Like one person hit the button and then everybody hit the button.
Dude,
I was locked in.
I was counting the seconds.
It was five seconds exactly.
I was counting.
He was counting the fucking seconds.
To the victor go the spoils.
Oh my god.
Yeah, big smiles.
I can't believe he counted.
Sorry, bro.
Minigame it.
Oh, another minigame.
It's like a back-to-back minigame.
Is that a GBA sound?
The Edge.
Oh, I know the strat in this game.
Wait, what?
Stamp out?
Oh my god, is this Mario Party 8?
You don't know what the strat is?
You hold down A...
And then you just jump and you...
Well, I don't want to give it all away.
There's a little secret.
It's like Splatoon.
Splatoon?
It's Larry Splatoon.
I'm ready.
Yo, why is dude AFK on my fucking phone?
Guys, target green!
We just need to make sure green doesn't get any color.
Totally.
Okay, let's get it.
Someone said just follow Kony.
No!
Just follow Kony.
Kony, you ain't ever winning, I promise you.
I'm satisfied.
It's all I wanted.
I'm getting bleed.
You literally have 88 coins, Kony.
I got 0 coins, you got 10 max.
It's fine.
You literally have everything going in for you, Kony.
I'm gonna pop my ult this round, watch this.
Alright, I'm watching.
Do the other voice line next time.
Don't do it, I won't.
Don't...
I didn't even hold back.
I was like, yep, that's Kony.
Isn't it scaled off of how much you have?
Dude, I'm fucking Ebenezer Scrooge.
I've been haunted by like 6 ghosts today.
This is ridiculous.
You shouldn't believe in Christmas, Kony.
I'm not learning the meaning of Christmas, bro.
You shouldn't believe in Christmas.
Fuck.
Bowser, take his star.
They wouldn't know what he does.
Do the thing where he splits coins.
Do the thing where he like...
Oh my god, make it so that all coins are equalized.
Then it's star in a circle, Bowser.
Not revolution.
Bowser revolution!
There you go.
There you go, that's big.
Whatever, I'll hold that.
If it was revolution, I would have been furious.
Wish it was Bowser revolution.
It would be so funny.
Oh, he did the snap.
That's a good snap.
That was great.
Waluigi!
I hate you, Waluigi.
How do you make that sound?
It's a left button.
His ass always looking at the board.
Old man trying to figure out the controls.
You can literally look at the top left.
It says 30 steps.
Oh, nice roll.
All that map looking just to get you to...
Big strategy.
Y'all alright?
Item minigame?
I hope it's the one he said he didn't understand.
I didn't know what the hell was going on on that one.
This is curling.
It's curling!
It's curling again!
I wanted that.
Maybe you should've taken a little bit more time to read there.
Yo, that was a half coin trap card?
That's crazy.
Waluigi!
Now, peep this one.
I'm watching the gamer mood.
37?
I have been waiting for this quad dice block to go.
Let's see it.
Yeah, but if he gets 40, he doesn't get the star.
He gets 4 tens.
4 tens.
40.
4 tens goes past the star.
7?
1?
That was Zarya.
That's a pretty good roll.
That's a good roll.
You know what?
I admire you.
This is fast as hell.
You don't stop.
Wait, what do you have?
Why is Waluigi moving so much?
He's jamming.
He's having a good time.
Morning calories.
You've got to be joking.
I have the mushroom.
Yeah, but that means you've got to use it.
That means you've got to use it.
You can't save it.
I was going to use it anyway.
It means you've got to use it.
Where do I go here?
I thought it was a jump pad.
I hate the creepy dice.
What is that?
Wait, guys.
Remember everything we've been through?
Remember all the stuff we've been through, chat?
Someone just got into my chat and said, Why isn't Matt streaming?
That's a bad sub.
What do I do?
I am Jack Jesus.
Wait, okay.
I can't move.
Slowest moving robot.
Relax.
It's check-in time.
It's check-in.
Doki, go down.
It's check-in time.
No, no, no.
We're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're such a little bitch.
It's okay.
I don't care.
I just wanted to get Kony.
It's okay.
You're such a little bitch.
That's fine.
The one that matters.
It's a moral victory.
Princess Daisy.
Doki is guaranteed to get Daisy.
That's crazy.
Wait, is that the strat to say you're gonna win so you never will?
Yeah, yeah, you gotta psych yourself up.
Oh, you just missed the pit stop.
I ran out of gas before hitting the pit stop.
I'm out of the race.
Wait, don't even say nothing.
Oh my god.
What do you need to read the board for?
Bro, he's speculating every game.
Make a move.
Just roll!
Don't tell me he uses the coin trap.
Ain't no way he uses the double dice.
Ain't no way he gets a 5.
Oh, he gets a 2.
Oh, okay.
There's no way he's gonna catch up to Kony.
Oh, he gets a plus 10.
Every round...
20, 20.
You get extra.
Wait, I'm almost first place.
That's scaling.
That's crazy.
I don't know the rules.
Items!
I keep getting cursed by all sorts of maladies today.
Awesome.
We do this.
We go to the shop.
We get something real nice.
We splurge a bit.
Okay.
See, now you're forced to use the ticket.
I did that.
You did that.
You did great.
Oh, he has double?
Bro, get the turbo dice.
There's no way you get more than 30.
Are these half off because of Daisy?
No, nobody's got Daisy yet.
Yeah, no.
Daisy is better than you.
For only 10 coins?
I mean, I'd do it.
Yeah, you can literally get extra money from that.
You'll lose first place, but whatever.
He still has 15 returns to get first place, so that'll be fine.
15?
Oh, sorry, 5.
I can't read.
Oh, now you're looking at the map.
Holy old man!
Boomer alert.
Only boomers read.
Alright.
I can say hi to Daisy and then everybody else is gonna take her from me anyway.
I will.
The instant I see...
Look at the totem!
That's how it works, right?
Hello, Daisy.
It was nice meeting you before I had to lose you.
I forgot.
Fight for her.
It's okay.
I didn't even want Daisy anyway.
It's fine.
She doesn't need to be my sidecar.
Wait, but if I get her, then I get two stars next turn.
You guys know what to do, guys.
Daisy's fielding.
The fuck is this?
What do you mean?
Explain why.
You skipped the text too fast.
Collect medals in four events.
Red medals are worth three points each.
Okay.
Daisy, give it to me.
Come on, young lady.
We gotta work together so Kony gets zero points, guys.
We're not even playing.
Thank you.
Thank you, kitty.
I'm locked in.
I get three medals at the start.
Let's go.
That's like nine points.
Yay!
Okay, but it's not gonna matter, though.
Daisy, can I have a red one, please?
Can I have that?
Thank you.
Yeah, let's go.
I don't even want Daisy.
Oh, my God.
Oh, now you don't want it.
I don't even like Daisy.
Oh, what has Daisy done to you, huh?
You won't give me any red coins.
Well, that's not her fault.
Is she so obligated to give you a red coin just because she has them?
Oh, yes.
Thank you, Daisy.
Yeah, she knows I'm a bad boy.
She knows I'm a bad boy.
Wait, what?
They went open world.
What the fuck?
They got no red coins.
What's going on?
What is this respawn?
Why does it take ten hours?
Yes, I got it.
Oh, man.
No!
Put me back in!
Put me back in, Daisy!
I'll turn around right now.
That was your mind.
I can't believe you chased me instead of just going to that plant.
Malicious.
You have 37.
How many?
Oh, my God.
My numbers going quite foolish indeed.
Red, let's go.
This is a scam.
Red coin, please.
Oh, my God.
I'm not getting that, though.
That's way too risky.
Why do I jump further than I'm actually jumping?
Get away from me!
Thank you.
No, that's mine.
Sorry.
That's mine.
That's mine, too.
Yeah, let's go!
Great games, everyone.
Wait, she's winning?
Guys, we can't let Doki win.
No, no.
I'm just a little guy.
Give it to Doki.
That's just a little guy.
Guys, this is...
What have I done to you guys?
Why does Duke have all the red coins?
Why does Cleveland flush away?
Let me down.
You're not getting that one either, Cody.
Target Cody!
Fight!
Unbelievable game.
I absolutely love Targeted Mario Party.
That was very difficult.
Now send that Gamer of the Year clip over to YouTuber Awards, too.
Right there.
Yay, Daisy!
Now we're best friends!
I'm gonna go this way because I get $20.
And I get a pipe!
Let's go!
I don't need a no.
Oh, and I get a second one, too?
Oh, I got another pipe.
That's fine.
Cody, how come you haven't crashed out?
Don't worry.
God is good and just.
Big Top Quiz.
We're always getting the money mini-games.
I think it has an ice rink.
Oh, okay.
Ow!
We just roll around.
Wait, what happens when we hit the snow?
We all know what to do, guys.
Thank you.
Oh, that's fucking right.
I think Brawl Pro is locked in right now.
I think he's locked in.
He's locked in right now.
He's waiting until the timer ends before he fucking crashes.
Let's go.
Who's getting that red coin first?
Alright, that's all.
I'm going in.
It's mine.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Are we really going to let him get that?
Yeah, we have to because he's too good.
If we went for it, we wouldn't get it.
Alright, open that up for me, Batman.
Thank you.
I saw that, too.
Wait, who got it?
I don't even know who got that one.
I can't even see who got it.
Thank you.
Yeah, alright, dude.
Alright, nice.
Doki won?
I did it because I wasn't greedy for the red coins.
I got the other coins.
Awesome.
Her ass cheating.
Yeah, I noticed there were no coins on the screen so I had to go for the red coins.
We had an agreement.
You guys were all too greedy.
You guys were just all too greedy.
And now comes my mythical third.
Oh, only five turns.
Homestretch.
What does that mean?
It means something happens.
Is this where they ask someone who's gonna win?
Oh, it's the predictions.
Oh, and then the last place person gets extra items, right?
Yep, I like that.
Red space is that.
And dual.
A special event for Homestretch.
One player receives a mushroom.
Oh no.
What did you get?
What did we get?
Oh, that's scary.
Oh, it's just more Bowser.
Oh, it's only that many.
Oh, it's not that many.
I wish we got the star seal.
The star seal looks good.
Yo, where's my freebie?
I'm fourth, hello?
Oh, I guess he doesn't care about you.
I guess you got...
Whoa, whoa, man.
You got the stop, though.
You get to refill items.
Fill her up.
Gotta give me something good here.
You know, I haven't gone there one time yet.
Double dice.
Oh, again?
Oh, creepy dice.
You know what to do.
I do.
Oh, two creepy dice.
You know what to do.
You're fourth place, you just sabotage everyone else.
That's my plan.
You know what to do with that creepy dice.
I hate the creepy dice.
It's too scary.
It's spooky scary.
Yeah, better not get a two.
That'd be some crazy shit, man.
You just get it back?
I think you just get back the money.
I think you get rewarded.
You get nothing.
Oh, it just uses it.
Does it use it?
No, he just got booted off.
Okay, yo, let's go.
He's closer to the star now.
Let's see.
What do you need?
You need nine.
You gotta use that mushroom.
Yeah, I need nine.
Wait.
Can I use two items?
No, I can only use one.
So I have to do this.
You gotta get four or more.
The love of God.
Please.
How do you make him do it?
No!
It is just.
Yup, this is how the game was always gonna go.
Thank you.
One star, please.
Someone get that swap.
Is there like the swap thing on this board?
Where you can swap stars with people?
I got a star.
Alright, we know what to do.
Are we going into the boo era of Mario Party?
Okay, it's at the bottom.
Okay, where is that?
It's at the bottom.
Oh, and he gets another item.
And he gets a triple dice?
That's pretty good.
This is why you're cursed.
This is why we all curse you.
Because I've used a bunch of them, which means there's probably one more.
That's pretty good.
Alright, Daisy, you know what to do.
The sight of Daisy with Waluigi makes me sick.
That's right.
Waluigi could never.
Wait, you could've used a pipe.
No.
I don't know where the fucking pipe goes.
She's gonna get money for this.
Yay!
Plus ally, no?
Yeah, yeah, and you get another 20.
I get 22?
Yeah, I get another 20.
Holy fuck.
The economy is in fucking shambles.
Oh, and I get to jump up?
The highest value dice roll.
That is such high, yeah.
I'm back here now.
Now I'm over here.
But you didn't get the store, and now you have all that money.
Wait, who's behind me?
There's somebody behind me.
I think it's me.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Dominic?
Me every single day.
What is modern warfare?
It's mash A, that's it.
Oh.
I'm not winning this one.
I think...
Mash the button for 10 seconds.
Then watch the... Okay, fine.
Alright, we know...
Coney's been practicing this.
I literally saw Coney do this.
Coney's been practicing this for like 200 boosts.
Oh my god.
My fingers are tired.
What did you guys do?
I don't know.
Probably not 108.
Yeah, probably not 108.
What?
I'm still lagging.
Oh my god.
No.
He's gonna die.
Oh my god.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
He was sharking me.
He was really good at button mashing.
This joycon button is tiny.
How do you even mash the joycon button?
I took the joycon and I literally just strained my brain so that my finger would move back and forth.
Pro is on the joycon.
That's different.
I thought I had to be because...
I thought there were minigame things.
Lost the joycon.
Joycon's better.
Don't.
Dude.
For what?
I have a triple dice.
It won't change a thing.
You guys are petty.
Awesome, man.
Great.
What's this?
I hope it kills you.
I hope it gives me a free star for no reason.
Electrocute it.
What is going on?
I have good energy.
This is a big thing.
This is a whole thing.
What?
What just happened?
I just changed the whole map.
That's weird.
Alright, alright.
That's strange.
Yo, hold on.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Pro's lost.
We've gone around the track 30 times and he's still lost.
Where's the star?
I'm just looking for the star.
That's crazy.
We've gone around this so many times, man.
I'm looking for the star, man.
Yo, there are two places for this.
It's been in the same two places all game.
How do I...
Wait, I'm on the pro controller.
Hold on, it's not.
How do I get out of this?
Okay, there we go.
I switched from the Joy-Con just now.
Alright, I'll take it.
Oh, he took Daisy.
Wait.
Wait, how?
If you just overtake the player, you take the ally.
Oh, that's sick.
Aw, dude, but I gotta go fight Bowser if I want the star.
Go for it.
You kill him.
You gap him, coach.
Get him.
But if he takes the star from me, it's not gonna...
He won't do that.
Wait, so Daisy also?
Wait, what if he doubles it?
Like, he takes two punishments because Daisy's there?
Oh, true.
Receive a thousand points?
They will never give that to you.
Even if you land it.
Oh, man!
You should lose two stars.
You know what?
I think you probably should have looked at the map and known that Bowser was there and not gone.
Maybe it wasn't worth it.
Maybe, yeah.
Maybe getting that was definitely...
You know what?
Deserved for stealing her.
Fucking deserved.
Yeah.
Wait a minute!
Let's go!
He did it!
This is...
What is this?
That's what you get.
Deserved.
He's not from Illusion.
He's not.
I don't even have any coins.
You got a star!
He gives you 20 coins because you're broke.
Broke.
Yo, can you refund this?
After this stream.
Alright, bro.
Get this cursed dice off me.
Watch this.
It's high noon.
Wait, you can cast on the cursed dice if you use your own items?
Well, well, well.
Look who it is.
She started it.
Literally, she started it.
You know what?
I'm hitting random.
Come on!
Bro!
Remember who sabotaged you in the minigames?
Remember who sabotaged you in the minigames, Kony?
Remember who it was?
Both of you did.
No, no, I didn't do anything!
I'm not denying that.
I did that.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I remember Kony did it like three times.
Kony did it first, though.
Good luck, everybody.
It's not me.
Oh, come on.
Yes!
Oh, no!
Well...
Goodbye.
There's your buddies, by the way.
Thanks for the star.
Delicious.
Big smiles.
Lose a star!
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Um, hey.
Donkey Kong is so scary!
Lose a star!
Lose half!
Oh, it doesn't matter.
He's broke.
It doesn't matter.
I ain't got no money anyway.
So long!
Goodbye, everyone.
God, it would've been so funny if you lost that star.
Bro, it's like back-to-back Bowser space, too.
That shit's scary.
Alright, I'm gonna use my mushroom.
I need this.
Give me that mushroom.
Okay.
Come on.
It's a one.
No!
Fuck you!
Fuck you, guys!
Here we are again.
Fuck you.
Yup.
That's tough.
Am I two spaces behind or nah?
I'm gonna get rid of this.
This is actually...
This fucking sucks.
Oh, I get another item!
Okay.
Gold pipe.
I don't think there is anything on this map.
Oh, there's not?
There's definitely not.
I don't want any of them.
They're all pretty bad.
Oh, no!
I'm confused!
I had no fucking way they expected to do that, by the way.
Mood!
Maybe I just don't have the brain for it.
Maybe you just can't.
Your eyes don't see more than 50 frames.
That's called being a gamer.
Alright, I'm getting rid of the...
Yeah, I lost my gamer privileges.
The pipe.
Minigame!
Yay, minigame!
Waluigi!
Big top quiz!
Oh, Matt failed high school.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Or are you just maliciously lying?
Study the images on the balls and then answer the questions.
The fuck?
There are two buzzy beetles and one sheep sheep.
It's probably going to be like...
They're not the buzzy beetles!
They're just fucking top whatevers.
Beetles and fish.
Which were their...
That's the quiz.
Alright, it's just memory.
It's just memorization.
What is it?
Crabs.
Three crabs.
They're kind of good at this.
Doki, stop.
Four crabs.
Wait, I can literally cheat.
We can...
Well, maybe whoever gets it first.
We can literally cheat.
Oh, it's whoever gets it first.
Oh, okay.
Follow Kony.
I'm just going to follow him.
I don't even need to read this.
I'm not even going to read it.
The fuck is that?
That's a buzzy beetle.
What?
Fuck, I was slow.
I was like, who's waving?
Oh wait, it's me.
I thought I was Waluigi.
He thought you were Waluigi.
I'm usually Waluigi in Mario Party.
Alright, I don't know what to do.
I don't even need to think anymore.
Yeah, I actually can't lose now, so I'm going to let you guys play.
Okay.
Is that me?
Oh, that's you!
Is that PokeKong?
Okay.
Bro, I already forgot what's what.
What are these?
Oh, right here.
Yay!
Your mouse was already on him!
Wait, that's right!
That's cheating!
You're literally above it!
I just picked the first one I saw, and I was hoping you guys would just pick it because I picked it because I was going to win anyway.
And then I got lucky.
Oh yeah, sure, that's how it goes.
Great game, everybody.
Guys, guys, just remember, he had two hours to play this, grinding this game before the clap, guys.
Just remember, guys.
No, no, no, no.
I just saw you on the minigame, babe.
Alright, you know what, coach?
Take that Daisy right now.
Oh, she left.
Goodbye, Daisy.
What was your double?
That's good.
Now nobody can have her.
No, that's bad!
She was going to leave me.
She left me once already.
She was going to leave me again.
I don't trust her.
You can't trust nobody.
All they do is lie.
What do we have?
Oh, you can move the star.
Wait, what's the glove?
I think the treasure chest steals an item from someone else.
This is a steal item.
This is minus two stars.
Wait, get the stars!
Get the stars!
That might be my only way to win, yeah.
Bro, ain't no way you're getting two stars.
Relax, okay?
You're wasting your money.
Yo, but...
Right now.
You're not even going to have the time.
What do you mean?
There's two turns.
There's one turn and I'm first.
This is the turn.
Lose your coins.
Take away his coins.
Come on, bro.
Come on, low roll.
Come on.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Yay!
And it goes to the top!
Doesn't matter!
Good game, bro.
Yay!
He's not a star.
I hate that the stars only go up and down.
Yeah, I'm just sort of going everywhere.
Yeah.
What a lucky duck.
Look at you.
Oh, look at you.
He's even luckier than the...
than the NPC right now.
Ever since the NPC took over, he's been, like, so lucky.
Watch this.
The Brawper just got that star.
It will be mine in two turns.
Yo, leave me alone, dude.
Come on.
I think we put this right about...
Right on the Bowser's face?
Wait, isn't that chance time?
That's good.
Get the fuck out of here.
Just in case I do lose something.
Can I do two?
So it's just if you land on it or if you cross it too?
You land on it.
You have to land on it.
Then I'm not worried about it.
Well...
Sure.
Alright.
Bro, who's the closest to the other star?
Wait, no, Matt can get the other star, actually.
If I roll high.
Alright.
I'm just gonna keep using my mushroom until something good happens to me.
Wait, how many vouchers do I have?
It's like four, I think.
It says it's anywhere from two to four, I think.
Oh, shit.
Oh, if only I got that last roll.
Ah, shit, I should've gone up.
Oh, Doki, you can steal stars.
Well, next turn.
What are you worried about, Mr. One Star?
As if I'm doing any better.
It's a catch.
So, you know.
Remember that.
I know what I want.
Get him!
What am I doing?
Other way, coach.
What's going on?
Oh, you guys are trying to catch me.
Guys, guys, guys.
Mix up, mix up.
Guys, guys, I don't know if I should be the button presser.
What?
Snoople!
How did I not get in?
Doki, lock in.
I'm trying.
We go up.
He's locked.
Guys, guys, guys.
Guys, please.
Guys, I need you.
Guys, we're not even above him.
How the fuck am I?
Guys, please.
Guys, guys.
Doki, you catch the boo, not the fish.
I'm trying, you're not even on top of him.
Oh my god.
Guys, guys, come on.
Guys, that wasn't my fault.
I blamed it.
It was never on top of him, guys.
What a play by your boy.
Average Canadian awareness.
Amazing.
Canadian awareness.
I blame...
I blame the guys that couldn't get the cage on top of the boo.
That's all I'm saying.
Can you imagine that?
Can you imagine that with the Wi-Fi?
What is that thing?
The Wi-Fi?
That would have taken a long time.
Doki, aren't you on that thing?
Oh no.
Wait, what?
Is that Mario?
No, I went the wrong way.
What does he do?
Nothing.
Oh, before hitting the dice?
Wait, that's crazy.
That's so annoying, I just went down.
I'm gonna get him.
He's gonna be in my pocket.
I don't like this, bro.
There's two turns left.
You should put it back.
I'm putting it there.
Yeah, put it in the back.
He's closer.
Oh, you can't.
You have to roll twice.
Yeah, I gotta hope that I get two decent rolls for these next turns.
That's decent, I guess.
Yeah, you just need to get six or more.
It's at the top.
I will try!
Just don't let Komi get it.
Just don't let him get it.
I need a six to get the star, yeah.
Oh, that's a nice roll.
Wait, do you have enough coins?
You have enough coins too!
You know what to do.
Star, star.
Steal a star.
He stole a star from you, remember that.
No, I didn't.
You will lose!
Do you understand that?
She doesn't care about winning.
She just wants me to lose.
I got ways to fix this.
Roast bacon on the star trap.
He's voting for star traps.
Oh my gosh.
Bacon on the trap.
It's the only way.
It's the only way I'll ever get them back.
Nobody's even going that way either because Wario's up top.
But I have to try.
I don't think I'm ever going to see anyone go down there ever again.
Money, please.
No one even wants the laps anymore.
No one needs the coins.
Everyone just wants to avoid the star.
No item for you.
That's some bullshit.
You're on it.
So therefore, I should steal your star.
I go up, so wait a minute.
I don't get another star.
Oh, it depends.
My turn!
My turn to look at the fucking board.
That would be the craziest 10 of your life.
Where is the part where I lose the star?
Oh, it's right here.
It's directly in front of you.
You might as well just triple dice it up.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking too.
I was going to triple dice it so no matter what, it won't get to me.
Unless I get really fucked over by the rolls like right now.
Oh, no!
I will never get it!
I never get it!
Everyone, space away!
That's what I got with my one roll.
He's literally winning.
He's in third right now.
We hit random for you!
I hit random for you!
He has the potential to get a star.
You have potential!
You're literally next to the star!
You're next to the star, Kony!
He has zero chance.
He's fighting because he knows I'm spitting.
You're next to a star.
He's the only person that can potentially get a star.
Matt sold you out, Kony.
Matt sold you out.
That is insane.
I'm not going to get a star!
I think it's more than 10 away!
That was a test?
That's fine!
If I lose the star, I lost Kony's star.
So that's okay with me.
Okay, give us Kony.
Bowser's going to give a star to Kony.
He's going to say Kony.
He's probably going to say don't.
Oh, that's fine!
I don't need that.
I have literally no chance to get the star.
I don't know why we agreed to that.
I don't know why we let Koji win here.
I don't know why that was so funny that we had to do.
But here we are.
Yay!
What about a win?
I don't like that.
Yay!
What about the bonus stars at the end?
That's real, Mario.
That's when Mario Party starts.
All of this doesn't matter until minigames start.
As long as Brawl Pro doesn't win the minigame star, he's fine.
Guys, you've got to make sure Brawl Pro doesn't win the minigame star.
Whoa, what is that?
Whoa, what are you trying to say about that, Kony?
Brawl Pro won more when he was NPC.
Leave me alone!
Yo!
Yo, malicious!
We're on a team!
A team fight!
Guys, we're on a team!
You know what?
Here, hit me.
Hit me.
Go ahead.
I'll take the money.
I'm okay with this.
You shared the money, right?
I lost all my money.
I'm dead.
I have CTE.
You're dead.
Awesome, man.
Great.
So cool.
Nice.
I did it.
I don't care if you lose points.
You guys didn't even help me.
What do you want me to do?
How can we help you?
Body block?
Yeah, where's the defense?
I thought you guys were a team.
What happened?
You guys didn't protect him.
No change.
Alright, bro.
Watch this.
Alright, the final turn.
He's gonna get Wario.
He's gonna get Wario, guys.
He's been waiting for the rest of us.
Oh, you know what to do with that creepy dice?
Absolutely not.
His ass is thinking.
Anybody's gonna land that, right?
On the last turn.
I feel like there's so many traps now.
It's funny that no one has landed on.
I'm just gonna send it and hope.
Oh my god, thank you.
Oh, you got it.
You got the extra star.
Wait a minute.
This plus bonus stars.
That one's longer.
The outside track is longer.
So, theoretically...
This is the last turn, though, Kony.
Which is the exact reason she's still a star.
Okay, alright.
Alright.
This is the last turn.
That's too far.
I think that's gotta be too far.
A clean ending as well.
Creepy bonus stars.
If I get the most haunted star...
Most haunted?
Oh.
Powerful.
You have to go up.
Down...
Downstairs is like the death trap.
It's over anyway, because it's the last turn.
They're not even gonna give him an item.
Oh, you can't even get an item?
Alright, how far?
Is it within 10?
You gotta hit 10.
This has to be the biggest character arc.
If you can hit 10 right now...
This determines whether or not you're a main character.
Yeah, it just determines it.
I did hit the 2 on my own trap.
Pull right here.
And do the overwatch ult.
The anticipation.
The build.
Only for it to be taken away.
Come on, what will it be?
What will it be?
I just need this.
Hold.
Abogado's your slew fish!
No!
What?
I win!
Why?
Oh my god!
Oh!
I can't believe it!
Not even the main character!
He's literally an NPC in our game!
He's an extra!
Oh my god!
I'm the boss!
That everybody had to team up to beat!
I'm LeDon!
Oh my god!
Mr. Mario Party himself.
I'm gonna make it shine!
Make my car shine!
They had to have a whole festival on how to kill me!
This is the guy that died in the first episode.
Gary Misfits!
Oh, look how shiny my car is.
You guys like it?
None of us got Wario.
Yeah, I just made it shinier.
That's it.
That was the only decision I had.
I'm gonna kill everyone!
I'll be free!
Get over there!
I don't wanna be on his team!
You know what to do, Matt.
You stole a star from me!
We jumped the gun.
I had to, bro.
It's competitive.
Yeah, he had to!
What do I do?
I make platformers.
I'm good at platforming.
Oh my god, why am I the platformer?
Oh, this is bad.
I'm good at platforming.
You can go further.
Oh, we can go next, actually.
This is not good for me.
This is not good.
We can go next.
We can just ready up and go next.
I don't know.
I don't know if Doki's gonna be performing on this one.
I don't think I'm gonna be Doki.
I don't think I'll be Doki.
Alright, we gotta hit start right now.
Okay, okay, this is fine.
It might actually be faster for Doki if I hit all of the targets.
Yeah, honestly, no, 100%.
100% it works.
No, these aren't hard.
Okay, you gotta have a little bit of a gap.
Okay.
That's fine.
Okay, believe in me.
I can parkour.
Believe, believe, believe.
Okay.
I believe in you.
I literally don't.
That is kind of like parkour civilization.
Don't believe in me.
Not when it comes to parkour.
That was all.
We were almost there.
I should have jumped for the chicken.
I jumped.
All he did was put the platforms down.
Alright, now the game starts.
Mini game time.
Mini start bonus stars.
The game starts now.
Give me the slow poke.
I need the slow poke.
Look at my incredible start.
Take it away.
And see if you can spot where the steal is.
A star for Boo.
And then...
Wow, interesting.
Cool.
Hey, great games, everybody.
The mini game bonus.
Obviously, that goes to Donkey Kong.
There's nothing to complain about.
You got the mini game.
And then, it's the slow poke.
Well, well, well.
There's no way.
I've been the main character the whole time.
Sometimes the bad guy wins.
Hey, I'm the superstar.
I told you you were in my arena.
I can't believe he was the main character all along.
I can't believe.
That's tough.
One via bonus stars.
Hard carried.
Carried by luck.
That's tough.
Hey, let's check the bonuses.
Oh, boy, look at that.
Hey, check the details, man.
Damn, look at that.
The misfortune.
I was so unfortunate.
Three reds, dude.
Wait, Donkey got zero reds.
I got zero reds.
I've been the luckiest.
Five items.
282...
Dude, come on.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he literally won.
I don't care.
Luck is not a clutch.
It wouldn't have changed, but it got me the red spot.
Hey, great work, everybody.
I can't believe it, guys.
That was fun, though.
I won the real ego match because I outmatched Kony in a Mario Party game.
Oh, that's true.
He was bragging about his button mashing just for him to get outmashed by Matt.
That's so true.
Outmash in a Mario Party game is...
You were on a Joy-Con, which is a little different.
Oh!
Now you're bringing up the rolling?
I just got so many achievements.
Me too.
I got like five.
Oh my god, there's Battle Pass.
Let's go.
I forgot Battle Pass.
Oh, is it mine?
Oh, they added Pro Role.
Oh, party points.
What does that mean?
Great game.
That was fantastic.
GG's everybody.
That was fun.
I had a lot of fun.
Yeah, you won.
Of course you had fun.
I had so much fun.
You guys want to do this again?
There are more maps.
Alright, fuck it.
Let's get back together soon.
Actually, I'm playing...
So on Friday, I'm playing with some other friends, but we can play after.
I'll do two games.
Sure.
I mean, I'm always not busy.
Alright, I'll be here.
Wait, can we get like slime in?
With the eight party?
There's an eight player.
But does that mean we can just make it five instead of eight?
Or does it have to be eight?
I don't know, actually.
We'll figure it out, but I'm doing it Saturday at like four.
So I think I'll play later, but we'll see.
Alright, we'll see.
Alright, sounds good.
Shoot them to me, because I got a bounty.
Brawl Pro.
Wait, what's the bounty?
It's for...
Tribe 9.
Tribe 9, the hot new game for the Danganronpa devs, I guess.
Oh, the Danganronpa devs?
Looks so cool.
Can't wait to try it.
Wait, can I get the bounty right now if I log on to Twitch?
Yes, probably.
I can't.
They don't give me bounties.
Bro, I asked.
I tried.
They keep telling me no.
I'm not big enough.
I should've streamed today.
I could've hit those bounties.
Yeah, you could've had those bounties.
Bounties are W's, bro.
Yeah, you get paid for those.
They don't give them to me, man.
They don't like me.
You gotta be a variety streamer, Brawl Pro, that you like the variety more.
I don't know why it's very exclusive.
Alright, we play Saturday, maybe.
I'll hit you guys up.
GG's!
Thanks for joining the collab!
Bye, everybody!
Bye-bye!
Oh my god, that was so fun!
I'm glad that we had our little team Brawl Pro reunion.
I can't believe fucking Kony won the misfortune award after everything we've done.
The bonus star was misfortune.
That's actually so fucking...
Oh my god, what is this main character energy right there?
Like, what the fuck was that?
I can't believe it.
It was so rigged.
Not last up.
Not last.
That's all that matters.
That's just Mario Party.
I didn't get last place.
Let's fucking go.
Oh my god, I'm trying not to laugh too much because I start coughing more when I laugh too much.
So I'm trying not to.
Um...
But yeah, I'm still coughing, guys.
It doesn't really matter if I don't stream because I just...
The coughing is just a thing that's been going...
I get it yearly, so like every year I get it once.
And then after, it's just basically like, I just can't stop coughing for a while.
Um...
So, yeah, it's just my seasonal coughing allergy.
So, it's alright, guys.
It's just gonna take a while to get better.
Because it always happens.
Even when I wasn't a streamer, when I wasn't a streamer, it's been like that as well.
So, yeah, the lingering cough.
Even when I wasn't a streamer, and I don't even stream or talk, my cough would last for weeks and stuff.
I just had to power through it.
But it sucks because it's so hard to laugh because when I laugh, it triggers a coughing fit.
So, I have to make sure I can't laugh too much, which is very difficult.
A lolly!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
That last mini game gave me a flashback to a certain Mega Man-inspired fan game.
Ba-dum, ba-dum.
Was great to see the gang back together.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah!
I'm so happy!
I'm so happy I was able to organize this reunion.
I'm glad that, like, Cody and I have been talking, joking about being like, oh yeah, let's bring back the bring back Team Brawl Pro for a Mario party.
It's gonna be so fun!
And I'm glad we were able to do it.
Yeah, Darkblade, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It needs eight players.
Maybe try and get Bryanco and SK for a full reunion.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Can it be, like...
The thing is, like, eight players is a lot of people in the fucking call.
Um...
So I'm thinking, like, um...
Could we have, like, five players and then three bots?
Like, is that possible?
I think, like, eight players might be just too many people in the call together.
So I'm not sure about that.
I think it'd be more fun if it was, like, four to five and three CPUs.
Um... But yeah, we'll see how it goes.
We'll see what, uh, Cody's gonna do because Cody's the one that's gonna organize the next one.
Um, but yeah, it's so much fun!
I'm really happy we're able to bring the boys back together to play Mario Party.
Bro, they are all, like, fucking Nintendo nerds!
They knew everything!
They knew everything about the fucking Mario Party!
And I'm just like, guys, please, let me read, guys.
Guys, please, I just let me, let me read just a little bit!
Just, oh, just let me...
I'm just like, please, I don't know what's going on!
Just, oh, just let me read!
Hahaha!
Anyway, guys, um...
Um...
Uh, thank you everybody for coming.
I'm gonna go rest my voice now.
As always, everybody, say hi.
Oh yeah, by the way, I talked about this with the members.
Uh, tomorrow, I said yes to a sponsor stream.
Um, so we have three streams tomorrow.
Well, two streams and then one off-stream thing.
One off-stream collab.
Um, so, we're starting at 12.
Um, we're, by the way, um, the reason why it's so last minute was that, this is for the Ascendant, by the way.
Remember when, like, we got the Ascendant playtest and we were like, we were like, hey, wouldn't it be funny if they sponsored me?
Hehehe, haha.
And then we tried to peer pressure the devs to sponsor me.
So, like, today, they were like, if you can do the sponsor stream tomorrow, we'll sponsor you.
And then I was like, if you pay me right now, I'll do it.
And then they paid me right now.
So, that's why we're...
hahaha.
We did it, guys!
We got him!
So, that's why the, um, that's why we're doing it tomorrow.
Cause I was like, if you pay me right now, I'll do it.
And then, cause, like, everybody has a price.
And, like, you know, I had a price.
They gave me that price.
They sent that money in.
And I was like, alright, I'm ready.
Hahaha.
So, tomorrow we're having a, um, the Ascendant, uh, the Ascendant, uh, sponsor tomorrow at 12.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you say that for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!